et comme on pouvait le prévoir le modem
le nouveau parti de françois bayrou est
loin de réaliser le même score que son
chef à la présidentielle françois bayrou
devrait être l'un des rares à sauver son
siège
pour lui la traversée du désert commence
cécile la ronce et loïc le moigne chez
françois bayrou ce matin on a la gueule
de voix le président du modem a réuni
tous les responsables de son parti à
l'ordre du jour
l'analyse des résultats du premier tour
il n'y a pas de consigne de vote
alors ensuite qu'au cas par cas on
puisse travailler sur une deux trois
quatre circonscriptions pourquoi pas
courtisé par le ps et l'ump françois
bayrou étudie les moyens de survie avec
un modem à -2 8%
il s'agit maintenant de sauver le
maximum de sièges
nous avons deux objectifs le premier
objectif c'est que dimanche prochain on
trouve en france le meilleur équilibre
possible
le déséquilibre le moins marqué possible
bien que les résultats d'aujourd'hui
laisse présager naturellement que ce
déséquilibre sera fort dans son béarn
natal
le leader centriste est contraint à une
triangulaire au second tour
il devrait cependant être réélu parmi
les députés sortants fidèle à françois
bayrou jean lassalle devra lui aussi
affronter deux candidats au second tour
dans les pyrénées atlantiques
mais l'histoire est terminée pour anne
marie comparini à lyon gilles artigues
dans la loire éliminés dès hier soir
bien sûr que j'aurais pu être élu si
j'avais dit que finalement nicolas
sarkozy était le plus beau le meilleur
que c'était le seul qui pouvait sauver
le pays
d'autres de mes collègues ont fait ce
choix là ailleurs en france
mais bon moi j'ai fait un autre choix
est alors sincèrement je peux me
regarder dans une glace des lendemains
qui déchantent pour azouz begag à lyon
où l'ancien ministre est éliminée dès le
premier tour
même scénario pour marielle de sarnez la
directrice de campagne de françois
bayrou
elle qui rêvait de conquérir un siège à
paris est-ce que ça va être compliqué
oui ce sera compliqué mais est ce que
pour autant ce que nous tentons de faire
ne vaut pas le coup d'être tentée je
crois que ça vaut le coup d'être tenté
en revanche les anciens amis de françois
bayrou qui ont rejoint nicolas sarkozy
devrait obtenir une vingtaine de députés